I've been searching a long time some way
to live for if you want to give your
life with us
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we're back again for yet another
episode of the 13 o'clock podcast hi
everybody out there yep I'm here I'm
here also well yeah wouldn't be as funny
if you were in here yeah what's the show
on today well today we are actually
going to be discussing cults creepy
cults and we just you know we didn't
really want to focus on just one so you
know cuz one cult is just not enough fun
on its own so yeah we're gonna do four
different 104 different ones and you
know we kind of tried to pick ones that
weren't quite as well no you know
everybody's heard of like the Moody's
and John Jim Jones and all that kind of
stuff so we kind of want to pick a few
more obscure ones but that we're still
terrible and resulted in many ruined
lives deaths what not good so that's
what we're gonna be discussing today
before we do that um let's see what have
we got to share news let's give yet
another shout-out to our mod Rossum Elia
and the project Entertainment Network
yeah and say you know they have a
patreon if you want to go over there
it's at patreon.com slash project
project and net I can't talk and so go
and give them a buck or two and it kind
of supports all of our podcasts I think
there are 14 or 15 on the network now
and we actually might be going on to I
Heart Radio yeah at some point yeah so
we don't we don't know yet yeah yeah
well wait and see what happens with that
um also another big announcement my new
book the unseen hand a new exploration
of poltergeist phenomena heads up is out
in print and eBook formats right just
waiting on audio book yeah and I have
also recorded an audiobook version and I
have uploaded it so if there's nothing
technically wrong then it should be up
by next week I would imagine yeah next
we'd have this date yeah or maybe yeah
you mean yeah binge watching at a later
date you come across this you can check
on me on Amazon it may be up by now
right okay so yeah it might be up by now
eleven and a half hours man so you know
I've just recognized cuz I had to sit
there and read all of it yeah hours of
entertainment and knowledge true yeah
that's true you get you get a lot and
get a lot for your money how many movies
is that worth well it depends are we
talking like Lord of the Rings movies or
like six out and six movies
Yeah right sure yeah yeah let's get to
it alright so what we're gonna do I kind
of have it broken down into four pieces
and we might kind of overlap or whatever
yeah but uh also if you like our shows
on cults we also did back I think it was
Episode four we did a show on
Scientology yeah an interview with the
angry gay Pope who is awesome
yeah and he's been asking to come come
on yeah we definitely have to get him
back on again cuz he's funny as all
along yeah he tries a Scientology uh
protester yeah he has a channel called
Darren all the end of Scientology right
so yeah I think it is or just look up
angry gay Pope um so yeah we might have
to have him back on cuz you know
Scientology that shit's fascinating but
these cults were talking about today
kind of more doomsday type cults
criminal activity mass murder mass
suicide things of that nature
okay what's cult number one so the first
cult we're gonna talk about is called
the order of the solar temple okay
now the order of the solar temple was
actually formed in 1984 in Geneva
Switzerland and the two guys that
started it I mean here's the thing the
order of the solar temple is definitely
one of those kind of
Eyes Wide Shut secret society type [__]
they thought IRA or will they believe
that they were you know the modern
coming of the Knights Templar yeah and
they were the costumes and everything
yeah so they had like they had the white
robes with like the Crusader
like the red crosses on I'm and whatnot
yeah I seen a lot of videos that they
actually look pretty cool yeah they did
real French real kind of
Renaissance slash medieval look like
some of our theory and legends yeah yeah
and you could tell they were like super
into that type of cosplay everything and
and the two guys that founded it this
was actually kind of an elite secret
society type of [__] they were trying to
attract you know wealthy people
obviously because they want to take all
their money but also because they kind
of thought they were better than
everybody like as which is why it was
kind of like everybody's very very
elitist the one guy Joseph Jomon bro he
was kind of a wealthy businessman other
guy Luc Jouret he started out as a
doctor but he I guess he got
disillusioned with quote-unquote
conventional medicines so he decided to
go be a homeopathic Ford unquote doctor
kids it homeopathy it's not anything so
uh he's so he was kind of famous on like
the New Age circuit like in Canada and
whatnot so these two chuckleheads
started this cult and they kind of had a
thing where they believed I think I
believe they thought it was 33 like
masters like spiritual masters or
whatever and that they were the ones
like getting all the wisdom for men
visit and it was very like it was a
Christian cult but you know they were
kind of like had a lot of ideas from the
Freemasons from Aleister Crowley like
all that kind of cults mysticism mixed
in with Christianity kind of white magic
yeah like they had you they did similar
kind of you know they had the robes and
they have like the swords and like they
had all these initiation rituals and
they were big into like Excalibur and
the Holy Grail and all that kind of
stuff you know like something what was
that book that was written with Jesus oh
right yeah Holy Blood Holy Grail yeah
yes that was the non-fiction one and
then right yeah and yeah so these guys
you know so they had this they had this
secret society and they thought they
were the [__] and everything like that
and the members that they had and
there's actually a documentary about
them on YouTube called the death of the
solar temple however I
watch that documentary two or three
times and that documentary it seems to
me that whoever made it was trying to
kind of push this kind of mystery agenda
that all the bad [__] that happened in
the 90s which I will get to in a second
was actually not what the authorities
said it was they think it was some kind
of big conspiracy theory like it was
some kind of like mass murder or some
type of thing like the government was
out to get them and stuff and it seemed
like this documentary kind of implied
that well Hanukkah getting out of order
what happened well here's what happened
right the first thing that happened
happened in Quebec and this happened in
October 19 yeah this cult this cult
actually was kind of cool yes France
Switzerland candidate was most rally
there was some in Australia's memories
but but the horrible [__] that happened
happened in France Switzerland and
Canada right now in October 1994 the
first thing that happened happened in
Quebec and what ended up happening was
there was a there was a couple that were
in the order but they had been evidently
they had been wanting to get out of it
because they were you know criticizing
or whatnot
and their three-month-old son Emmanuel
was killed they pounded him through this
through the heart with a wooden stake
several times several times right now it
is believed that one of the leaders
Joseph Dammam bro ordered this murder
because he believed that Emmanuel was
the Antichrist and that he had been born
into his order to screw up the call to
screw up they call it like to [__] with
him yeah and here's here's something
else that we probably have to mention to
them it wasn't kind of like the nature
of the cult itself what they would do is
they would put on these big ceremonies
they dress up in robes it was real kind
of Masonic and white magic II and kind
of what he call it kind of medieval
looking kind of kind of a kind of cool
kind of romantic looking yeah I've uh
ceremonies and they would actually have
I guess you could say spiritual masters
come out through the Braille Alba and
talk to them and teach them
yeah where's ghosts would come right but
how they were doing this was through
like a holographic type image like
projections and then and these ghosts
these ghosts that would teach them all
these spiritual truths would also bring
them ancient artifacts to prove that the
lesson was real in other words it
brought them the sword Excalibur yeah
all right lit and then another time it
he actually brought them the Holy Grail
yeah it brought them a some kind of holy
menorah that was used words that use the
Last Supper no not the menorah it was
supposedly and inside the Ark of the
Covenant with the commandment yeah this
is actually the menorah camp oh that's
right yeah so these call these cult
worshippers really believe this stuff
and they believe that all these ancient
mystical artifacts were coming from the
other side and then yeah and they were
showing it to them to prove and they
were paying big money to see this and of
course of his magic tricks but they were
also being told that there were
reincarnation of famous people like you
know Saint Francis of Assissi and stuff
like Joseph of Arimathea your Joan of
Arc reincarnated yeah one of the things
about results is that if you people will
pay to feel good about themselves they
flattered right flattery and these
weren't losers that were in this Coast
oh no these were all like upper middle
class you know successful businessmen
there was actually cops in this cult and
they were more loyal to the cult than
they were to the law or to law
enforcement yeah you know they were
actually helping in some of this stuff
they were trying to help secure
silencers and things like that because
they were trying to build an arsenal to
which that's kind of a long story
yeah but anyway their time ran out and
the cult leader for one reason or
another ordered mass suicides and
murders inside the cult
yeah and it all happened across the
globe within a short period of time well
the same day well the first
three things like I said the first thing
was this murder in Quebec with this
little boy and the and his parents and
then a few days after that Joseph de
Monroe was one of the leaders and twelve
of the members of the group they had
liked this ritual Last Supper or
something like that
and apparently a bunch of them like
wrote suicide notes and things like that
and they're saying that they've been
persecuted and the laws after them and
they thought they were being watched
they thought they were under
surveillance yeah they were also really
secret agent
they were secret agent D yeah they were
a it was this cult yeah really a lot of
cults are just perverts and douchebags
and in this case they weren't really
like that I kind of thought this cult
was kind of cool in that aspect they
were they were weird but they took they
took it seriously they did yeah like I
said very very freemason II yeah like
something out of the movies but um then
there were two evidently mass suicides
pretty much the same day there were
there were two villages in Switzerland
and then there were a bunch of people
that were in the cult fifteen of them
they poisoned themselves thirty of them
they found were shot or smothered and
there were eight other ones I think that
were killed in other in other ways now
some of the bodies they found were
arranged in like a star shape like with
the feet pointing like inward and they
had plastic bags over their heads and
they were shot and they were shot and
what was weird is that they were all
shot with the same gun in one case
evidently yeah yeah one case whether the
90 rounds were fired 60 I think it was
65 85 on 30 something people yeah it was
yeah and so some of them were shot
multiple times in the head yeah can't
shoot yourself in the head but it was
all the same gun yeah so what they were
doing is that I guess everybody was
shooting the guy next to them and then
passing things like that facet it was
because like I said here's the thing
that the documentary that's on YouTube
like I said they kind of made it want to
seem like oh
this big mass murder or they almost
implied that it was like because oh they
were under surveillance and the
government had them killed it was some
kind of like cloak-and-dagger kind of
[__] I don't think that's what it was
because like I said the documentary one
they left out the fact that that little
boy had been staked to they left out the
fact that a bunch of the members had
written suicide notes autumn had been
drugged shown signs of being drugged
yeah and a lot of them had been drugged
I think what happened and also it should
be noted the two leaders were among the
dead yeah um so it's not like they're
like we're just gonna kill all the
followers and get the [__] out with all
the money
no because they did make a lot of money
because some of the people that were in
the cult were like millionaires and [__]
yeah did like you know donate to the
church like millions of dollars that was
the weird thing about this one is
because it usually cults will
self-destruct when they're falling apart
right this girl wasn't falling apart it
had lots of money it was doing a hell
that you would think that it would have
continued on they just did it for a
right angle actually there might still
be some members now in a few other
countries but you know like I said there
there's kind of like they don't know if
there was like some kind of schism
between some of the members because some
people had left like one guy they
interviewed for that documentary named
Thierry something he had been in it for
like 14 years and he left because he
thought there was like some kind of you
know schism developing with the
leadership and the members and stuff
like that so maybe they thought and
that's another thing they're almost they
had the aspect of a UFO UFO cult too
because they thought that the 33 masters
or they were gonna go see the 33 masters
were serious right this star yeah they
thought that's where they were going so
it's kind of like Heaven's Gate where
they thought they were going to the hilt
okay I'm better whatever you say alien
spaceship in the hale-bopp got it could
also been some along the lines were they
had made a bunch of prophecies like end
times prophecies and they knew that they
weren't gonna happen and to save face
they all killed themselves type of I
don't know cuz that is kind of common
for that kind of [__] that didn't that
happen with the Millerites and [__] like
that because I thought oh it's gonna be
the end of the world that was like the
didn't have
they said well must be next year and it
didn't happen again well imagine if they
were hardcore enough they maybe there
could've been a possibility where the
cult leader would have ordered them to
kill themselves yeah that's the end of
the world yeah here's the thing like
weird I'm convinced cults I'm kind of
fascinated by cults because in a lot of
ways you'd think like the leaders and
stuff like that like Jim Jones and
people like that in a way like yes
they're manipulative [__] and
they're trying to get money they're
trying to get power they're trying to
get sex you know over people but in a
lot of ways I think they're true
believers too because a lot of them when
they do these mass suicides think a lot
of times they go with them well they're
delusional yeah ask me they're
delusional and their trend it's kind of
like a face-saving
device yeah you could kill yourself you
don't have to face up to the fact that
you failed that you failed yeah and you
know I'm that you were a fake and they
and they kind of do I mean just like the
Heaven's Gate people were like oh well
we're not killing ourselves
quote-unquote we're going to meet the
aliens and they're gonna take us off to
utopia or whatever and if they actually
do believe that yeah I don't yeah
Heaven's Gate didn't kill themselves
because of failure they actually thought
they actually thought that they would
get them yeah meetup that their souls
we're gonna leave their bodies and then
we're going to go into a UFO hide by the
tail Bob copy and that's pretty [__]
awesome that's hardcore I think if that
was true oh they're coming to get us and
these were not stupid we're getting
ahead of ourselves these are not stupid
people they were you know making
websites and they were crazy but they
weren't stupid
yeah these super were actually reasoned
into this yeah that's the one of the
things that always makes me skeptical of
reason and intelligence don't listen to
your reason listen to your gut listen to
your gut is some but if you can't reason
me into giving up my children or
something like that there's some
pedophiles or reason me into taking
poison to go to the hale-bopp comet I'm
too dumb I'm too dumb to be amazing well
here's the thing just know that that's
not gonna happen here's the thing my dad
she used to tell me right but also I
think I have a different approach I
don't consider myself a dumb person I
consider myself a pretty smart person
however I am the world's most stubborn
skeptical person and pretty much
anything anybody says
me I'm like that's [__] until I find
out otherwise and especially if somebody
says to me hey I need your money hey you
know all this you know you're better
than everybody you know we're going to
this utopian no no no no I have that is
never the case
yeah ever yeah in the whole entire
history of the human race that has never
been the case in case you dream yeah so
it's like if anybody ever tells you that
just run far far away because that is
just that's never gonna happen it's
never gonna end well
it's just not and if God says you can
have sex with children
then no you need to run whatever you
will especially talk about that I mean
and yeah that actually leads me on to
the next move on to the next name this
is solar - that was order of the solar
temple oh yeah if you want that that's a
good case she says want to learn more
about it so yeah order the solar temple
the mass suicides murders whatever they
can't recover all the 74 people 74
people we're presenting this stuff to
you yes in case you didn't know we can't
cover all this stuff in the show yeah
another time but 74 people that's
episode that's about that I think so
that's how max now the next one we're
gonna talk about this one is a little
bit better known because this one had a
couple of famous people that were raised
in it as children that's affected later
on Rose McGowan was raised in it River
and Joaquin Phoenix yeah I'm also raised
in it although they got the [__] out
wisely although River Phoenix is dead
now so I don't know but um the children
of God yes that now that was their
original name these people are still
around yes although now they are called
the family or the family International
actually is what they're called you may
want to stay away from this one yes
definitely stay away from this one they
say that it's all right now it's not the
way it was but I don't buy that like I
said everything is [__] everything
she's goofs and especially anything to
do with religion you come at me with
anything religion but no I'm not
listening yeah I just know that's never
good it's always tricking a book it is
so the children of God actually started
in the 60s it's funny because the
founder of it David Berg who later came
to be known as Mo
David Berg because he was leading his
people out of the wilderness or whatever
here we go I know just automatically I'm
just like oh god my eyes roll so now he
was raised by in a very fundamentalist
Christian family his mother was a very
well-known holy rollin preacher they
went on tour his dad was also a preacher
so he was kind of raised in that
fundamentalist milieu and oddly when the
children of God first started it was
actually a very fundamentalist sect you
know no sex no drugs no alcohol no
anything like that and that's not and
they and they wanted to start out yet
witnessing to the hippies because they
felt like oh this is a lost generation
they're looking for meaning
blah-dee-blah so they kind of went out
to San Francisco and start trying to
witness to some of the hippies and out a
new market yeah now at first it works
like at first they got some hippies that
were like yeah okay I'm down with that
no more sex no more drugs yeah but yeah
that did alasa
that now that's a hard sell it is a hard
sell nobody wants to do that as the as
the cult progressed yeah it kind of
turned into the weird combination of
David Berg's perversions well I became a
hippie free-love call pretty much that
that you could basically do it with
anybody at any time anything you wanted
yeah incest pedophilia everything
prostitution yeah then it became a
church of pimp see it was pretty much
yeah if it started pimping out their
women I started alone in their children
to each other yes bizarre yeah this is
bizarre and and then they're ordering
videotapes made to prove to prove to the
leader that his Commandments are being
followed that yes grandson and grant you
know grandson and grandma are doing it
it's oh it's bizarre
yeah they even had like books with
pictures how-to illustrations and
everything yeah and the women look like
Farrah Fawcett it's just like David
Bowie like I said David Berg he kind of
had like I think he kind of had a
fucked-up childhood I mean
I think I was yeah I read that his mom
once caught him masturbating you know
like he do and and her and his mom made
him finish masturbating in front of his
dad was because of like you know that's
what you you know that's shameful and
why are you doing this and you can see
how that would kind of mess reverent
yeah I'm not excusing the dude because
he was a snob I made that up he might
has made that up I'm just saying that
something I read but yeah so as the cult
as the cult progressed like throughout
the 70s and stuff like that very
communal they would basically like Dave
Berg a total pervert like he was just
hurt he wanted to bang all the women
everywhere at all times
and also all the children all children
yeah and the cult members I don't know
like it seemed like a couple of them
left like when they because they're like
what the [__] man yeah yeah they all
started getting into but they all
started getting into it now he women we
regard for the little boys and the
little girls of this bizarre yeah they
would basically they would take the kids
of the cult and they would you know they
like a lot of cults do they separate
family units yeah you know so they can
kind of control people better they raise
the kids communally under like they'd
have like a few nannies in one room like
for an 80s and the nannies would be
having sex with little kids yeah
everybody be having sex with each other
they'd be videotaping it yeah sending it
to David Berg so yeah it and what was
the weird is that they were commanded to
do so yes they're commanded to do this
this is some crazy crap yeah it just
goes to show you you know you can hire a
man religion you can you can sell even
sell people anything yeah sure you gotta
watch it it was acceptable to religion
or susceptible to other things too
not all of them but yeah well now here's
the thing
like I said they they got into a lot of
trouble for the pedophilia and all that
kind of stuff now like I said after
David Berg died after he died and then
his wife took over and they say that
they don't do that anymore
yeah and so but I don't I don't buy it
like I guess they couldn't find enough
evidence you know from the modern so
they've been kind of you know they said
yeah we don't do that anymore that was a
long time ago but I have to point this
out now David Berg he had won his grand
daughter has specifically said she went
to live with him when she was what like
eight or nine or something like that and
she has alleged that he molested her
yeah which wouldn't shock and she had
all kind of mental breakdown yes
and now another boy that he raised as a
son da bd2 they called him his actual
name was Ricky Rodriguez yeah if I his
son nobody knows who's related to who it
yes well no it wasn't his biological son
it's just I think it was his wife's son
with another dude
because everybody was just [__] it
because there was a see has a certain
part in that cult where nobody knew
whose daddy was who yeah because
obviously they didn't want birth control
they were just all humping everybody and
then they would just all have these
babies they called him Jesus babies
jesus babies so Ricky Rodriguez called
Abbey detail now David Berg actually
wrote a book it's like 800 pages long
says giant he did like these Jack Chick
like comics yeah like these [__]
twisted nicely drawn I have to say but
[__] up and there's some pictures of
him online it's it's pretty special but
he did yeah well but but he did this
giant book the width of like these
illustrations like a comic book kinda
about like how to raise a kid and it was
about David eat oh yeah and there are
photographs in there of this little boy
like it's like sucking on his nanny's
titties and like sleeping is just a very
like sexual they're very weird yeah and
you know it's kind of like I don't know
they kind of had this thing where it's
just like oh well little kid it's
natural like everyone should just [__]
everyone it's done with love so it's
okay yeah okay well yeah here's what
ended up happening with that Ricky
Rodriguez when he got older he had been
molested he had been whooped by one of
his nannies maybe by his mom yeah and he
was very angry he built up an arm
Bowden's he's gone he made me come to
Parcher he's got to be come upon he made
a video when he was older when he was
I guess in the video I don't remember
how old he was maybe 20 but he made a
video of all these weapons like on the
Tate on this table and he said I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna kill my mom and I'm
gonna kill him all Yeah right and he's
like but you you can't blame the guy
right he's gonna go Frank Castle he was
he was gonna go Frank castle on the
[__] children of God because they
[__] him up and he could not believe
that it was allowed right so he made
this videotape and he sent it to a
friend now that was a weird thing some
person for some reason the federal
authorities did in those days where it
wasn't they weren't do anything about it
had something do with their religious
freedom see ya oh you can you can have
religious I don't know if they really
knew about that at the time I think
those kinds of allegations came out
later ago like it's kind of hard to say
because you know that he did eventually
come under investigation they did yeah I
had to stop it yeah but yes so he um he
flipped out he went looking for his mom
he could not find her because evidently
the mom heard he was coming and went
into hiding or something like that
however he did find one of his nannies
who was molested him anthro he slit her
throat enough to rap and then he shot
himself yeah and you know like I said it
was terrible it's a terrible story and
actually if you're interested in this
call - there is I think it's called lost
and found and a lot on it yeah and and a
kid who was raised in it with him and
his like 11 siblings he made a
documentary like after he escaped and he
kind of it and it's actually a pretty
fair documentary like he talks to some
people that are still in it now yeah you
know that are just like oh it's all good
and they don't do that pedophile thing
anymore whatever and [__] like that
that's we don't really know that's right
that's a good one you guys should check
out I think there's pretty much covered
that one on this because it's almost a
break oh yeah it's okay
we're at the halfway point so we'll
probably talk a little bit about that
you know after the break and then I got
a couple more I want to talk about too
so we will be back in just a few minutes
every person's story has something to
teach us
however is view life how obstacles are
overcome how joy is felt how fears are
faced how love is expressed the matters
of faith podcast explores individual
stories of people's lives and how faith
plays a part it may not be your story
but it may help shape yours the matters
of faith podcast with Jay Wilburn is on
project entertainment network subculture
corsets and clothing is our favorite
store for unusual clothing shoes and
accessories they offer a wide selection
of men's and women's clothing at great
prices
soap culture also offers the cool
selection of shoes and accessories
steampunk gothic apparel retro corsets
and so much more at subculture corsets
and clothings check out subculture
online at subculture corsets calm
that's subculture corsets calm make sure
you use the discount code 13 o'clock for
a 10% discount subculture corsets comm
or visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 or cast dead sexy
podcasts
I'm your host Armand Rose Amelia Fridays
exclusively on project Entertainment
Network where I interview authors
publishers editors artists filmmakers
narrators the lady from Walmart whoever
I feel like talking to that's every
Friday arm cast right here on project
entertainment network
[Music]
specializing in posters and flyers
special rates for bands and artists
quick turnaround times
books and CD covers consultations
through email or skype logos and
packaging
payment through PayPal
ads in promo materials satisfaction
guaranteed visit the Facebook page and
Hollow Earth design or email Hecate
eight hotmail calm alright we're back
yeah we got two more right yeah alright
what's next okay the next one I wanted
to talk about is called the movement for
the restoration of the ten commandments
of God
oh that's at one in Africa yes yeah now
this okay yes this this cult is in
Uganda and it's actually a spin-off of
the Roman Catholic Church and it was
started in well actually it was formerly
it was started in 1989 but you know it
has roots going back farther there they
were like a lot of sightings of the
Virgin Mary oh yeah in Uganda evidently
and so some of these people who I quote
the cave I very I guess but so so all
these people claimed that they had seen
the Virgin Mary and you know these
people kind of got together today let's
form a cult you know there and you know
this cult went on for a while they
opened some schools they opened some
other things like that then
interestingly they actually when they
formed the cult they got a lot of
defrocked like nuns and priests in there
to like kind of help them out and [__]
like that that was kind of interesting
so they kind of yeah they're trying to
like a like a lot of these cults
apocalyptic okay you know they kept
saying you know the world's gonna end on
this date and blah blah so you know they
they pre-printed this was in the 90s
actually the you know like I said they
started in 89 and then they kind of went
through the 90s and actually by kind of
the late 90s they kind of had a big
community going they had you know like
big they had a big believe it was kind
of like I said it's kind of like a
Catholic sort of offshoot like I said
they thought that all these people were
seeing the Virgin Mary cuz the end of
the world was
and you had to repent and all this other
stuff and they had like all these super
strict rules you're trending back up the
10 commandments an Old Testament stuff
yeah like they were very very strict
League adherent to the Ten Commandments
ain't no sex
yeah no talking right yeah weren't
allowed to speak right they had to use
sign language yeah which is a boys tell
about the Ten Commandments and really
you know if you read Exodus there were
Ten Commandments and then those were
lost and then new Commandments came I
think there was 11 after that yeah and
then there he added to all throughout
Exodus there's about another 150
Commandments a lot of them like how many
shekels a sheep was worth you know but
it was a you know sacrifice of the
firstborn all kinds of stuff sin Exodus
so it's not just the Ten Commandments
it's also all the other Commandments you
get Mosaic law just trying to bring that
back man be worse than Isis because it
was absolutely insane yeah and it
contradicted itself and then they would
erase laws and make new ones like you do
oh yeah God changed his mind
yeah like an omnipotent being yeah well
middle-eastern potentate that lives out
in a garden out in the middle of a
desert
yeah see the weird thing about this felt
like I said they they wouldn't talk
because one of the commandments is thou
shalt not bear false which is a night
guys bear false witness and I guess
they're like well we don't want to you
know take the chance that we might lie
or say that's not true so just don't
talk special however they will also had
they also admonished people not to use
soap where is that in the text now let
go ask dr. price cuz I'm like where does
it say you can't be clean I don't get
that I'm sure it's in there
everything like that everything's
everything's in yeah so like these
people thought I think they kind of
thought of themselves kind of like oh
we're like Noah's Ark the whole world is
depraved and it's gonna end and with
this kind of this one community that's
gonna survive so what happen is for well
they kind of got famous for they like I
said they thought the end of the world
was coming and they genuinely I guess
they genuinely thought this they took
all of their stuff all of their cows
their clothes their land everything like
that and sold it and they sold it for
super cheap okay right and they so they
thought the world was going to end on
January first two thousand year many
years later so since the end didn't come
you know people started leaving and
people like what the [__] and it's like
you know people were asking questions
like about the leaders like why did it
happen you said it was gonna happen
coming through Miller right yeah and um
you know so a lot and a lot of their
timing you know the tithing amount
started to dry up because more like you
guys run out full of [__] right right
and so a lot of the members you know
Rebell there was like hey we want our
[__] back right you know we want our
land back on our cows back whatever and
so the leaders thinking quickly we're
like no no we mean the world's gonna end
on March 17 mm he's like no this is
really for real the world's gonna end
this time okay obviously it didn't it
didn't happen then either so uh you know
but they have this big party and
everything like that
now what ended up happening though was
they said okay the world's gonna end on
March 17 so everybody from the church
like comes to this town at canoe I think
is the name of their main like base and
they said we're gonna have a bull we're
gonna roast a bull it's gonna be a big
[__] party and the world's gonna end
whoo and what ended up happening was
they got all the people into the church
and they nailed them all in there and
set the [__] on fire yeah from the
inside there are people in there that
said
environment yeah well yeah there was a
guy at the door like I think only one
dude escaped like he was like oh I gotta
go get some [__] you know salsa yeah
they burned themselves up now what ended
up happening here the leaders escaped
though didn't they did yeah so actually
they didn't really consider this a mass
suicide like a mass murder as much as a
mass murder right now this ended up
being and it was a lot of people they
thought initially they thought a
thousand you know so it's like a
Jonestown situation it's about seven
seventy eight that's about how much they
think it was now seven hundred seventy
eight people and I think I believe was
in two churches but but they had the yet
they had them all locked up in there and
they set it on fire and there are
pictures I'll put them in the YouTube
video but they're pretty gross I'm just
like just sees of charred bodies now
they also later you know the leaders
took off initially they thought the
leaders also died in the fire right but
no they didn't they skated they so I
guess like the leaders were just like oh
[__] the jig is up everybody wants their
money back the world's not gonna end
whatever and so will just kill all of
them and then yeah yeah well what I've
got yours I don't know I don't think
they were caught no God no beer yeah
what's a beard into the wilds of Uganda
yeah now what ended up happening to was
that later when they discovered that the
that the leaders had taken off they went
and checked out their houses and they
found a bunch more bodies there yeah
like they found him like down into
latrine pits and all this other kind of
[__] they had um there was another
compound in another town and they found
a hundred fifty-three bodies there 155
bodies at one of the other leaders
compound so her his house they had been
poisoned and stabbed right so it's like
they found like all these [__] dead
ones so these people killed like seven
or something people of their followers
Wow and I think they still don't know
who like where they were like where the
leaders right one of the biggest comers
yeah I mean Jonestown was nine hundreds
of them but yeah this is like seven that
they know as one of it that they know of
and they figured out most of the people
like after they got all the charred
bodies like out of the
ruins they found out that most of them
had been poisoned at first they thought
they'd been strangled because they found
like banana fibers around their necks
and something like that but so yeah a
lot of them have been poisoned so yeah
it was like a Jonestown type situation
where you know just hundreds and
hundreds of people like [__] man can
you imagine can you imagine like just
nailing these people into this building
so and just setting it all on fire it's
just this that's horrible and I'm sure
it [__] smelled horrible around there
what's in it but um yeah so like I said
I don't think they're still an
international warrant for the leaders
arrest but I don't think they've found
them at this point another one I wanted
to talk about I kind of wanted to talk
about South Korea a little bit because
for some reason and maybe a lot of
Westerners don't know this but South
Korea is a pretty is a Christian
countries more or less and they're
presbyterian right yeah and so as with
many other Christian countries just like
the United States there are a lot of
cults Christian Christian type cults you
know everybody's heard of the
unification Church obviously the Moonies
yeah and stuff like that fascinating but
there yeah but there are a bunch of
other ones too and some of these have
also indulged in some mass suicide mass
murder type things I just want to tell
the audience in case you guys didn't
know but Reverend hunks on the moon you
know right actually claims to have ended
the Cold War by going astral astral
projecting and fixing the Cold War from
the spirit world that's how it ended
that's pretty awesome yeah yeah River
Moon something else that's the kind of
[__] well because there's no way to
prove that so you can kind of say yeah
fixed it on the other side yeah I sorted
that [__] out yeah you're welcome
awesome meal you can't fix North Korea
though well no and it's right there no
no okay so what happened well okay so
these two cults are kind of interrelated
the one is called as in English they're
called salvation sect I guess I can't
I'm you know I don't speak Korean
obviously
but the it's called go on pas I guess
this is way the rooms but it's called
the salvation tax law now these people
were in the news they were actually
founded in 1962 but they turned up in
the news in 2014 when there was um there
was a fairy called the the MB Sewell I
guess and it sunk and it's 300
passengers died and the leader of the
cult whose name was yoo byung-eun he
owned the ferry through his children
like there was some kind of weird like
labyrinth in sort of thing like so so
they thought that the cult had something
to do with the sinking of this ferry and
the co-owned it yeah well he owned it
like they felt leader of it yeah the guy
that had started the cult in 1962 he was
like this was kind of a thing
sort of like to order the solar temple
like this guy that started this cult was
kind of like a successful dude he was
you know businessman he had a lot of
money it's like he was an artist and you
know he gave a lot of money to museums
or whatnot but you know so after this
ferry incident happened was 300 people
died they actually sent out like an
international thing because they thought
that the cult had something to do with
it now I think it turned out that later
he had been on the ferry and he was dead
because for a while they thought that he
had skipped out of town weird
he turned out he died with that but he
turned out with the he died with the
ferry also now the interesting thing is
that there was another mass suicide that
was related to this guy because there
was this other cult and it was called
Oda yang right or paradise I think is
another name for it and this was founded
later in the 1980s by a woman named Park
soon-ja and they cut her followers
called her the benevolent mother now
hold on one second
what so the one cult the one call to
this that lost the ferry yeah okay this
what was the various about that how is
that related to this one well this guy
actually the guy I was gonna get to that
okay before you arrived
I have to know kind of know I can't tell
you everything upfront okay I mean you
keep going okay this is what I roll okay
now see this is this is why he's getting
to be like he's getting like old man
disease yes that we're like we're when
you're watching a movie cuz you're like
what what happened cuz you guys you guys
you know no offense no old farts out
there I'm got you but if you go to
movies with old people they can't just
watch the movie and let [__] happen and
like I'm just like you know just calm
down
everything okay explain and somebody's
what's going on
why did that happen oh yeah so that
already so you so you promising me that
these tutor related they're related okay
all right well I'm just saying well no I
said the guy that started the salvation
sect he was actually in prison for fraud
okay you know later so he was kind of
sketchy but I'm just saying this with
the woman that started this other cult
OT yang she was in his cult okay and
then she called part two yeah this is
yeah this is like an offshoot like he
started his in the 60s
she started hers in the 80s and she was
also kind of a piece of [__] her yeah
well she she actually heard like I said
her cult members called her benevolent
mother what is with Koreans in this
benevolent leader and supreme leader
what is that him well you know I you
know I lived in Korea for a year you
know we have at least one audience
member that also served in Korea
Koreans South Koreans are all drafted
pretty much yeah you have to serve in
the military or you have to have rich
parents who somehow get you out of it
but you know most Koreans end up in a
pretty disciplined kind of a traditional
society everyone has military experience
everything seems to be kind of
militarized yeah including the religion
yeah so you know I mean I get to join a
religion and it kind of has kind of a
military structure or a government
structure to it you know and even their
Christian and their Christianity came
from the middle
actually they just adopted the religion
that was in general mcarthur head yeah
cuz they saw General MacArthur as their
Liberator that liberated them from the
Japanese they convert it to MacArthur's
religion and I think it was Presbyterian
I think yeah but with his sect his
Christian sect and everything it's weird
because I was reading this article about
cults in South Korea and it seemed like
they were trying to make it seem like oh
there's more cults in South but then
there were kind of like no there's the
same amount of cults as there are in
other Christian countries I'm like then
why even bring it up Christianity is
free because enough to where you can
make your own church and interpret it
yeah the text because and then they kind
of pointed I was like oh well Asians are
more into like following directly yeah
but they have cults here too
Scientology still a thing I'm like
obviously Americans are not important
differentiable mystic because they fall
for this in Korean Koreans like
structured yeah organizations yeah
that's really all of this but
Scientologists detail yes because that's
exactly why in that environment I do
yeah I love I love those kind of orders
it is Seattle like that yeah I don't
raised in it I don't like I don't like
corporate structures I don't like
hero-worship
I don't like anything like that it's
just very in case the audience doesn't
know I actually grew up in a sub in the
Southern California military academy yes
is a Christian Military Academy
yes no I loved it I had big remote
descending to military school yeah that
kind of and I love being in a structured
society that has yeah like I would
thrive and it until toss her in
dictatorship I would just love that yes
yeah I don't know I don't know because
like and like I wasn't raised by hippies
or anything like that but I was raised
like a lot more just kind of like yeah
whatever do whatever you want this you
know they weren't ruled I wasn't raised
real strict and I did I really really do
not like any kind of shirt anytime
somebody is like hey do this I'm like no
I'm not gonna do that no it's good that
we it's no because you're weak why I
don't need anybody to tell me what to do
well no I liked it too I like to I like
to I think you command and I'm gonna
I'm good I'm a good follower and I'm a
good commander see I'm not a good father
both yes it'd be able to know how to do
both and I don't let me des M yeah via
top like that like that I'm just well
I'm - I'm - Ari I don't like this like
following other people and I don't like
being told what to do ever yeah but yeah
I tell you what to do but and yeah I
don't do anything okay so this woman
okay so this woman Park soon jobs she
started this offshoot cult right also a
Christian called also apocalyptic
world's coming to in it I don't know why
people keep falling for this ship but
they do world still here you know
newsflash
so we want the world the end they do
well because that's the thing I think a
lot of the problem here with these
people that get into this kind of [__]
I'm not saying they're dumb I'm not
saying that I'm just saying one I think
I think it happens a lot to people that
are losers or they're kind of like
oppressed or something like that in some
way because I feel like they're like
well I want to be special I want to be
able to be here after everybody else is
dead so I can [__] on everybody else and
say I won that's kind of like what I
feel like they they want they want
everybody on earth to die and them to be
one of the elite that survived because
they feel powerless in their regular
life yeah because mostly it's people
that don't really have a lot going on I
guess other than order a solar temple
which is a bunch of rich people whatever
I kind of liked that one we're special
we actually have spiritual masters
coming bringing us the ring in there I
totally agree
that's kind of an awesome concept which
our costumes are cooler than your cast
they did have cool and we have our own
assassins assassin's creed they're like
something directly out of says that's it
probably exactly yeah it's definitely
like a video game cosplay yeah that's
how their costumes look like I will see
they didn't mention this they didn't
mention this in anything I've read about
them but like so did so okay so did the
leaders actually do they go to like Pier
one and buy like a cool-looking cup and
say you guys everybody's like blah
Wow you know I mean I'm like I just kind
of wondered about that because they did
say about the ghosts and stuff like that
yeah it was just projections and
separately they said the artifacts were
looked convincing well yeah well I can
get like I said I don't want to worry a
guy thing go to Pere wanna buy something
that looks like the [__] Holy Grail
well I wonder where they got Excalibur
they had the sword Excalibur yeah yeah
wonder what wonder where they got it
just something that they bought well
yeah good here's the thing you can't
just go buy that online or something
this is back of the day yeah because
somebody else might recognize it
oh I know who makes those it would have
but it would have the label on it well
here our sword making companies oh yeah
yeah buddy maybe he had a custom it
might have had a been a custom yes like
he went and had one customer cuz if he
had a lot of money and if he was trying
to commit and like I said that kinda
would have aged it right yeah although
if it wasn't although if it wasn't aged
they could just say oh well because it's
like magical it's looks brand-new looks
always brand new cuz they can always
pull something out of their ass that
people all right you know how I said the
Hamina sword let me see if I can stick
it through that stone although the sword
the stone was not Excalibur now people
mess that up yeah sword the stone was
just a stone idiot you needed that to be
king it was a lady the lake yeah two
different sorts two different stores
yeah so so yeah so like I said this this
woman she started her little offshoot
cult in the 80s they thought the world
was terrible and decadent and they were
the only ones that were special enough
to survive in blah-dee-blah and the you
know the world was gonna end now she was
actually kind of a wealthy person
socialite you know she had like a lot of
charitable organizations whatnot and her
husband was kind of a High muckety-muck
in the local government but as a cult
leader she was kind of a hard-ass you
know she was like real you know
demanding discipline and stuff like that
now it came to light later the cops got
onto her case because she had swindled
almost nine million dollars from about
220 people which here's the thing if
you're gonna swindle nine million
dollars make it from one person because
seriously if
swindle like money from a whole bunch of
people what a bunch of those people are
gonna gang up like that if you just
steal from one person then if that
person is our spotter you can just
that's the same as stealing a thousand
dollars and nine million it's the same
it's just one person yeah just take it
from one person just you know that's my
advice varieties nothing don't do it
from two hundred twenty people you're
gonna get it terrible so yeah so they
knocked on earth they went to the police
okay so many and many of the people that
she swindled the money from were in her
cult right right so since she decided
you're not taking me alive copper right
house like you do they decided to go the
mass suicide route she had a factory and
they found I believe it was thirty two
yeah it was her and thirty two of her
people and they found them all dead in
this factory so she went with them okay
you know like you do she yeah I guess
not and you know they were much like
they have it well not like the Heaven's
Gate cult but they all kind of had the
same office they just had underwear on
but they have pajamas on and they said
most of them had been tied up and had
been strangled or poisoned but it didn't
look like anyone had resisted so they
all went willingly evidently the how was
that conversation go man it's like she's
like well I'm sorry I took all your
money but you know we're all gonna go to
jail the world's gonna end and let's
just all take poison and gave him some
kind of line she used some kind of ruse
yeah Antichrist is coming or something
like that and that's another thing and
and that's another thing and I think
this this has also been kind of a common
thread and this was a common thread
always persecution yeah in kind of a
life is short it's gonna say that and
particularly in the order of the solar
to in the case that ordered a solar
temple and in the case of children of
God and this happened with the Jim Jones
People's Temple also and that's kind of
a good way and how a lot of cult leaders
manipulate the people is by saying you
know the outside world they don't get
they're trying to get us they're coming
to get us
that's how Jim Jones got all of them to
go to Ghana right because he was just
like oh the government's coming
like that and the same thing ordered the
solar temple rightly or wrongly the
leaders that believed that they were
under surveillance by the Swiss
government which maybe they might have
been I don't know I don't think they
were but I don't think they were I think
it was paranoia they thought they were
more important than they really were and
that's another thing that I was gonna
say a lot of these kind of cult groups
and especially I mean the order the
solar temple I think it was only what
like a thousand people yeah in like
three countries there might be more of
them now I'm not sure but um that was
all the members that they knew I'm like
that is a tiny drop in the ocean yeah
you know what I mean it's not like a
cult with and even an even Scientology
in this country as big as it is I don't
think they have nearly as many men house
I mean them less than $100 yeah very big
thing now that they have so much land
and they have so much money and [__]
like that and they have a lot of
celebrities Wow now Scientology is now a
real estate scam yeah that's really or
more or less just buy up as much stuff
as you can because they can't hoard
money yeah so you just keep raising
money fundraising fundraising funder it
from a smaller and smaller group of
people yeah to try to convert that that
money the money the parishioners into
real estate
yeah empty buildings yeah so they have
tons of buildings that are contacting
yes and they're bleeding followers yeah
and eventually what they'll do is
they'll close the church down the mill
auction all that stuff up all that all
that stuff off and re-engineer that
church into something else yeah I'm kind
of curious though because and we've kind
of talked about this a lot and regards
to Scientology and other cults and stuff
like that I think I definitely think
that the onset of the Internet has
really kind of been a death knell for a
lot of religion religion in general and
cults I mean I think what you're seeing
now I think you're seeing some like a
lot of extremist religions coming out
now but honestly I think it's cuz that
that's because they're dying out and I
think they're panicking yeah you just
don't see they just don't have the same
kind of power that they used to have you
know now that you know in five seconds
well you can you find out ok I know you
can't lie to anybody anymore you're not
right let me find out the history of any
church or any Co you can find out the
meaning of any holy scripture yeah you
can see all the
as criticism of Scripture yeah and you
know you can't really keep things secret
anymore like we used to be able to write
and I think that's a good thing and
honestly I think it's funny because when
I was growing up you know i I've been an
atheist since I was a kid which and and
I remember it that being a pretty you
know a pretty a pretty [__] up
position because I most of all were most
people weren't almost he wouldn't even
talk about it in our lifetime has
changed a lot yeah I mean and so even
from the time I was in school in the 80s
to now the the decline I've seen in
religious belief is just it's more than
I thought would happen
honestly well I you know I used to
believe in Noah's Ark yeah I was a kid I
used to believe in the exes
I thought those are actually happened
did they actually well but as I got
older I went you know what the flood
didn't happen yeah
and I said that Exodus happened yeah and
then you a little bit overweight a bit
hold on no you see if you see the
actually the historical analysis and the
critical analysis of what that story
means is where it all came from you know
where they borrowed things now that
didn't happen either yeah whoever wrote
this you know that's probably 300 BC my
neighbor yes so you know they're talking
about a mythic tale yeah placing in
thousands of years there's nothing wrong
with that it's like it's there's a
mythic tale
yeah and I love mythology yeah I mean
that's kind of the whole reason that I'm
and I'm into biblical mythology I love
Greek mythology I love all that [__]
Sumerian all babble and all that that's
a lie no they're not lying they're just
making stories that make the stories
they're telling you what they know yeah
and story I heard you know and the story
always explains something and they're
making up stories you know to explain
things that they don't know how to
explain any other way would she know
fair enough library you want know more
about that just go back to her Robert
price biblical mythology show yeah and
you talked a lot about dr. price came
out and he you know he laid out a good
basic introductory course yeah yeah and
also good at his channel because he's oh
yeah I loved I loved his always stuff
about Genesis at flexing yeah thing yeah
um oh [__] okay so we're almost at the
end of the show yeah so I've got to
mention one thing what do you got on
Heaven's Gate yeah you guys gotta go on
YouTube and go look at Heaven's Gate if
you haven't I mean I know there
goofy those followers were they all
didn't they smiles they do like these
little alien smiles like they're
extraterrestrials maybe they were aliens
maybe that's them
their speech was kind of messed up and
some of the guys had at their own last
year's there yeah they would call it
they emasculated themselves like guilty
themselves we call it castrated cast
ourselves sound like an old
Attis cult yeah yeah where you got to be
[__] up there you've gotta believe in
that you got to believe that in whatever
yeah there's no way you're gonna
half-ass no but just believe you mustn't
you really believe that [__]
jesus said to cut your dick oh yeah all
right well in this hair goes it in that
case you know really it wasn't indeed
Jesus of course that was I do it the
alien said the cut of your body is not
yours you're actually an alien soul
inside of an animal body and we have to
be called aliens again and you know they
killed themselves so their spirits could
go up and and they even made the odds
maker they're gonna dock up with the
without the halo in the tail the
hale-bopp comet and they they thought
they they thought their souls were alien
souls that came here a long time ago on
their uniforms when it said the earth
away team yeah the earth away the always
get away team away team like they were
yes it does to trust felt off but what
one thing in the defense of Heaven's
Gate everybody who knew them like they
evidently went to Big Boy a lot yes of
course they did it all babies everybody
says that they were that they were super
friendly super friendly they were real
harmless yeah impose their beliefs on
anybody else which that's cool Mike it's
sad that they all kill themselves and
then they were deluded and stuff like
that but they didn't hurt anybody else
they were supposed to be goofy I mean
well I guess they hurt them and they all
went out willingly they did that always
yeah they all had video tapes they all
have video tapes ahead of time
like saying that they were going and
saying you know no one forced me and
blah blah go back to outer space yeah
that's weird man maybe they're up there
right now peace out you guys approve of
the cult leader tricking them into that
but he believed that he was mentally ill
he did believe it yeah and they were all
mentally ill well yeah and there comes a
point where it's like you can't I mean
they're all adults
yeah you can't protect people you can't
really protect I mean if they're gonna
believe that and that's what they go as
long as they don't take anyone else out
yeah yeah yeah no children were harmed
yeah so you know that that's why that's
you know probably the shittiest like all
this mass suicide kind of stuff but I
mean I'm talking about like the [__]
children of God called yeah like they
were just like molesting kids and stuff
like that isn't that a Croce's yeah yeah
that's just that's [__] up man yeah
okay so yeah we're into the end of the
show hope you like the I know that was a
little unfocused but whatever that's all
we're talking about call TA and we got a
guy's gotta remember we present these
cases for your entertainment and
youthful to go out and study more if
you're interested you have study on your
own yeah I just wanted to mention these
four cults because I thought they were
interesting we're just presenting them I
thought they were interesting and they
don't get as much air time for us some
of your some of your bigger ticket cults
you know what I mean nice you know you
guys but you didn't you fail to mention
that on August 30 forth to the FBI that
no I guess 34 so yeah that's the end of
the show so like I said earlier go to
project entertainment networks what's
happening why my old man disease never
oh yeah see how you do
we're super real okay we're recording
this on the Monday after The Walking
Dead Sea's that what's bad what yeah and
is like the whole times like what's that
what's she doing what's going I'm like
witches I'm like I don't know either
oh they'll tell us it's fine buy some
t-shirts yeah but some t-shirts
diesel.com size 13 o'clock and buy some
t-shirts go to yeah go to
patreon.com/scishow and get a lot of
cool [__] and go to their store also
because we have an exclusive t-shirt
that's different than the ones on our
it's [__] story and listen to us
listen to a starry night yeah they're
friends of ours really good bands yeah
they're from Miami they're like you have
to get them sighs they're like they're
like a dark wave kind of you know indie
band yeah if you like Interpol if you
like cure and Karen Joy Division's never
leave stuff like that yeah yeah you'll
like them they're awesome and so that'll
do it for this week's episode about cult
and we will see you next Tuesday bye
[Music]
you